some fun news for you guys a new report
ranks the most popular emojis
in the world adobe surveyed 7 000 people
and they said the laugh
out loud face is their favorite it was
followed by the thumbs up
red heart emojis the wink and kiss
and the sad face with the tear round out
the top five those are the ones i get
from brian
but i think my mind
which one the wicked the kids
stop it i do a lot of i use a lot of the
i just noticed i use a lot of the face
to palm
one you know that one that emoji oh you
do yeah i do a lot not with you though
all right you want to hear something
interesting my the uh the emoji that my
family loves
the one with the little eyebrow up
because they say that it reminds me oh
yeah yeah right i don't know
do it again do it again oh yeah that's
it yeah yeah yeah all right that's right
pondering one right with the spectacles
that's another one
i'm thinking i think yeah that one or
the smirk
yeah those are good or the eye you know
the eye roll that's a good one
our viewers are like okay we got the
picture